priver leurs à présent de notre rubrique
du vendredi soir des rencontres variées
à la découverte des réunionnais après
jean philippe le sdf qui vivait sous le
pont du verger à sainte-marie encontre
ce soir avec une jeune femme un jour
avec anne-laure morel chercheuse et
chefs d'entreprise son projet est
ambitieux elle souhaite révolutionner le
traitement des cancers avec des plantes
pays et pour son portrait on vous
retrouve jean marc collienne et laurent
figon à sainte-suzanne ce soir nous
sommes avec un de leur mort elle cherche
scientifiques chefs d'entreprise bonjour
anne laure benjamin on est à bagatelle
dans les hauts de sainte-suzanne qu'est
ce qu'on cherche on cherche de l'or ma
ville c'est avec cette plante que je
sais de mettre au point un nouveau
traitement contre le cancer
c'est une jeune femme de 35 ans qui n'a
peur de rien cet après midi elle a
chaussé ses baskets pour nous emmener à
travers champs et ravines à la
découverte de cette plante leur baville
grâce à laquelle elle a l'intention de
révolutionner le traitement des cancers
sportif
anne laure morel a rendez vous
aujourd'hui avec ses fournisseurs
les responsables de l'association plante
nout racine salut ça va
et vous merci regarde moi cette qualité
de jean basile l'amba ville pousse ici à
l'état sauvage
mais il en faudra beaucoup plus lorsque
le traitement mis au point par anne
laure sera commercialisé on peut très
bien faire plusieurs poches comme ça et
replanter de lamballe il mais pas la
peine de partir dans différents coins
mais on peut avoir
ouais sur les traces des sur place
accord ce sont des portes qui sont déjà
utilisés par les petits canards ce sont
des plantes ils sont déjà utilisés pour
les par les tisaneurs en effet
donc pour traiter les problèmes de peau
voilà principalement est-ce que c'est
fréquent que les scientifiques qui
travaillent sur la base de ses
connaissances un peu anciennes notamment
celle des tisaneurs non c'est pas très
fréquent on voit en inde on le voit en
chine
on le voit à maurice et à la réunion en
afrique et donc on est très content
d'eux d'avoir développé ce protocole
innovant verts qui utilise que des
plantes de la région et de l'or pour
fabriquer ce nouveau médicament contre
le cancer pour mener à bien son projet à
north morel a créé son entreprise une
start up stores call qui est basé ici à
la technopole de saint-denis aussi roi
la plateforme de recherche et
d'innovation en biotechnologie une
pépinière d'entreprises qui mettent à sa
disposition des laboratoires on va
retrouver alors en plein travail et en
tenue de scientifiques cette fois nous
retrouvons anne-laure dans son
laboratoire en pleine opération de peser
là j'étais en train de peser la poudre
dans ma ville c'est dans babine qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure dans le champ
exactement donc là ça a été on a extrait
les composés d'intérêt et on les a
lyophilisés c'est de la poudre dans ma
ville c'est de la poudre dans ma ville
ouais la réunion un produit pays
ajoutez un peu d'eau mélanger le tout le
premier ingrédient est maintenant prête
à l'emploi
c'est une recette oui je fais de la
cuisine lui l'alchimie plus tôt car anne
blanc va maintenant mélangés dans ma
ville avec de l'or ça c'est de l'or ça
c'est de l'or l'or
sous forme audio de sels métalliques et
[Musique]
de cette couleur
jaune
donc là je vais solubiliser l'or dans de
l'eau donc ça c'est notre réaction c'est
notre solution d'or l'occident que je
vais introduire dans le ballon alors
échauffés à 50 degrés il ne reste plus
qu'à introduire lamballe ville vous êtes
prêts parce que là on va avoir des
nanoparticules d'or
dans un instant les deux éléments ne
feront plus qu'un cette réaction j'adore
mois scène
c'est la magie de la chimie là c'est la
rencontre entre l'or et des plantes de
la réunion ouais c'est ça c'est la
rencontre une rencontre alchimique entre
l'or et les plantes de la réunion c'est
votre bébé là que vous avez entre les
mains
oui c'est un fait ça c'est mon précieux
là on va bien le changement en couleurs
c'est ce mélange couleur grenat qui
après avoir été refroidi centrifuge est
stérilisé deviendra le médicament
qu'anne-laure espère commercialiser
d'ici quelques années et les traitements
mise au point par rapport aux raids sont
déjà testés actuellement sur qui vous
allez découvrir de l'autre côté de cette
porte attention on entre en zone à accès
réglementé chaussures blues charlotte
nous pénétrons dans l'animalerie du
sirois en suivant scrupuleusement la
charte d'éthique sur les essais animaux
le traitement mis au point par anne
laure va être administré à des souris
qui ont développé un cancer sous cutanée
et il faut bien viser car l'injection se
fait dans la veine de la queue de la
souris après 45 minutes le temps que le
traitement injecté se diffuse dans la
zone malades
la souris est passé au scanner afin de
vérifier qu'il s'est fixé au bon endroit
j'ai hâte de voir l'essai doit permettre
de vérifier que le traitement cible
précisément les autres malades sans
détruire les cellules saines comme le
font souvent les traitements
traditionnels intéressé à certains
plaques chauffantes pour les sauver
dimitri le physicien de l'équipe lui
travaille déjà sur l'étape suivante
un dispositif pour irradier au lazare
les nano particules injectées dans les
souris et ainsi détruire les cellules
cancéreuses
du coup je me suis couché un peu tard
parce que j'ai fini le business plan
dans son bureau anne leur mort et leur
dos à présent le rôle de chef
d'entreprise sa start up stores scal
emploie actuellement quatre personnes
cet après midi j'ai prévu d'appeler
yolanda aussi pour faire un point sur
notre déplacement en chine car les
prochains essais du traitement pourrait
avoir lieu dans un hôpital militaire
chinois les premiers essais sur l'homme
sont programmées en 2019 avec l'espoir
de soigner dans un premier temps les
cancers de la peau alors on se retrouve
pour terminer au milieu des tombes à
villa quand vous voyez votre parcours
vous dit c'est quoi qui vous anime qui
vous donne la force de faire tout ça on
imagine que c'est beaucoup de travail
beaucoup d'investissement c'est surtout
le comment dire le vécu
j'ai perdu beaucoup de proches du cancer
et donc forcément ça vous anime
vous avez envie de trouver des solutions
avec le plus rapidement possible vous
vous dites je vais sauver des vies je me
dis chaque jour que je vais sauver des
vies web vous souvenez depuis depuis
qu'amd a quel âge vous avez ça a
commencé à déclencher
je crois que depuis tout petit en fait
je songe à être sauvé
[Rires]
je me souviens que mon papy me disais
qu'est ce que tu veux être plus tard
qu'est ce que tu veux faire
puis je répondais ben sauveuse c'est par
amitié mais en tous les cas j'ai envie
d'être utile
voilà j'ai envie d'être utile
j'ai fait ce choix je veux vraiment
réalisé ce projet ici à la réunion sur
la terre de mes ancêtres
enfin une partie de mes ancêtres parce
que ma maman et de bordeaux et puis j'ai
envie de montrer que bah ouais quand on
est une femme une réunionnaise donc issu
d'un tout petit caillou dans l'océan
indien peu quand même mener des projets
de ce type là un peu fou c'est vrai mais
pourquoi pas et puis je crois que steve
jobs en fait là beaucoup inspiré il
disait style anglais stay foolish et ça
ça je crois que c'est
je vais rester là dessus et m'ont
inspiré parce que c'est ça motive tous
les jours
ouais ça ira gaulle stay foolish avoir
faim continue à l'être flou pour avancer
ouais